la mode suit ça se bouscule en ce moment
c'est le cas de le dire yale salon de la
mode masculine et la présentation des
collections les couturiers qui voit loin
en sont déjà à la ligne printemps-été
1990 mais oui ce soir yoba grégoire nous
présente une petite sélection très
éclectique
regardez-bien couleurs d'un parfum de
vacances dans les tropiques flotte sur
la collection balmain que si mme patrick
aubert j les pastilles sur pantalons
larges comme des joggings de costumes
toujours classique léger prince de
galles chemise unie cravate plus large
couleur terre de sienne costumes sans
revers souple près du corps léger comme
de la soie c'est adolfo dominguez
couturier espagnol leader dans son pays
et installé dans le nôtre depuis peu
akin devant cette collection aux tons
chauds une mode élégante très
décontractée pour tous âges
jean paul gaultier fait bande à part
sont en ma visite d'inspiration guerre
14-18 est de retour
toujours un lieu amusant pour ses
défilés ici le cirque d'hiver normaux
les pantalons amusant les gie les
asymétries inspiration mad max pour le
soir ambiance totalement distroll gens
pas de se sentir que c'est un vrai que
parce qu'il sait nous amuser